yeah I'm fine thank you so much my
levels agree what so full podcast man
welcome to the Warsaw fool podcast we're
here every we know what we're here
whenever we find the time to do this but
most of the time we're here on
Wednesdays at noon to 1:30 or 1 o'clock
p.m. it's live on youtube.com slash ATC
we're doing it up we got out well three
go Toor is right here man yeah man
Johnny rocket just showed up you know if
the POWs cabin Commodore gij got
released over the weekend release on
Sunday
lucky arrested in early release on
Tuesday at least as far as I hear my
wife and that agree people actor yes
writer yes documentarian yes all the way
Bob but no jail time first time I saw
him look towards a Black Angus oh my god
like a get bro oh the next week some
loose cannons were fighting to get rid
of the room yeah into the black veins
like a bro hey bro I was one of the
first brothers man the only thing you
got meant in any one the easterly side
with all the Latinos both the spot that
they used to chose to kill us yes and
Willie's Bar and Grill yes in Wooley
person actually had to get me out of
there one night oh you the first brother
to started doing office at a Fernandez
at the end of your solos bikers and sha
allah so my mom goes your mom about
different types of bikers there in
cholos one-percenters yes yeah that was
a that was a you know it was a rough
spot but I love man I did a lot of rooms
over there man but you know I was
hanging out you know my roommates at the
town with Latinos who the roommates uh
to comedians not many people know we're
part said I'm Jeff Garcia and Oscar hell
no no
no cause no college didn't live with us
no I thought he lived her you know hun
right yeah Carlos was going it was me
Willie it was Willie Jeff and myself in
spring of Silver Lake on Occidental in a
freaking studio Wow that's throwing I
was upstairs a mother in the restaurant
with a straight right exactly Nancy 11
yes that would let me do her to cook
fish yes Jack real quick what Willie
said that is all a bro he eels in the
room a bro he's one of those guys just
ended up sleeping on the couch bro yes
bass do it it was small the dinner table
yeah he had a wonderful I remember like
one time I was there once
he bought me the nannies and it'll you
don't know you don't know how to eat bro
but you're eating right do it right bro
cuz I'm gonna eat it off the black
tea-tray you know lead with Prince
Edward and I said now bro you gotta flip
it over just flipped it over but we're
not ready to plate a miss the crazy I
got two crazy stories don't tell her
though know me bro okay the first one
was it was Jeff and Willy and they was
you know we were always cool and I knew
Jeff when he was like Jeff was only 16
16 years old wearing the dice man jacket
yes you know you gain so so I come home
one day because I was working for
Federal Express with you guys that's
right you want better explains the FedEx
for seven years bro I used to flip it
would tell you I would leave my I worked
ten hour days I would leave my job and
if I didn't bring my clothes I would go
to the comedy clothes in my fedex gear
do a show go home yeah take my clothes
to work on a Friday
shower and then go to the clothes do
that for seven years straight so one day
I come home from work and I go up in
there Jeff and will you're gone
and I look in the fridge and it some
touchy fried chicken in it what a note
talking about don't eat the chicken
now you gonna tell black man note there
was a notice it bro [ __ ] you know I mean
yeah so am i leaving the a bro there's
five talk will don't need them yeah yeah
so I ate the chicken and the $4 that was
the first but here's the crazy story in
terms of living in a small facility like
that where I'm I'm sleeping I got you
know I have work I work 10 12 hour a day
so I used to try to hit the bed about
10:00 10:30 I gotta get up to go
downtown FedEx by seven o'clock in the
morning so I'm sleepy yeah yeah and will
he come in with two girls
now if you know the place was small and
it was lined up right and it was like a
it was like a room they had they had a
bedroom but it was so small bros like a
bedroom for just a board across so here
and their party and grow up a storm I'm
not getting no sleep they're in there
partying and drinking and laughing then
when they they want to get they open the
door to go to the kitchen and then they
open the door he goes Shh [ __ ] I'm
sleeping if you got through the door
there's no it was thinner than this like
the whole thing it was just a crazy town
man but it was a good time man I gotta
admit it was a good time and he helped
me out because I had a terrible roommate
man I was almost getting the fight once
everyday well it was like yo bro you
can't be creative in that so you so I
got I know where that gets me but he was
he he gave me love he gave me love man
and Willie didn't fight you at all no
will you fight me me me me we were the
bad Willie Willie was a kicker and
moisturised you know I'm a two-time
Golden Gloves champ so that would have
been a good battle but me will over
being cool just like me Felipe that
Wales dog yes so you come on now you
said you knew where do we know you came
to uh the
it was tortillas in before I only want
Gotham's yeah but it was tortillas at
the particular time I believe it's 2003
you came that's one about yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're a while but you were
promoting a movie that you just made at
that time was roommates and then yeah
Willie to the size of a bro sleep in the
couch bro you didn't have room bro
didn't have a room I was helping them
out you're like between apartments your
country what it was I was supposed to be
there for two weeks because I with my
income tax which of course it had a
Rochin in there no I never knew that one
I'm happy I didn't know that could I
dare to check my clothes man right over
no roaches hang with brothers I don't
need that one third Oscar said we had
colored Oscars here okay
I don't know historian said oh you left
our note I eat the last piece chicken
yes I did yeah I love to know and I
looked at my dollar okay yeah but you
know what this going in now the story
gets this story it's like bigger yeah
you know I left a note and some extra
raw chicken you know and I left a note
there was a dog sitting by the fridge
way I'm a I don't know man speaking of
chicken man do y'all he only put up a
pose or earthquake of a woman showing up
your wife says I'm not to be seen you a
cup of burgers let me tell you what
happened you know I kept hearing about
it and I'm and I'm like you know cuz I
go live a lot on
on Facebook and Instagram so just to be
silly so I said you know what let me go
see it this chicken as good as they say
it is so I go to the Popeyes Chicken on
victory and Vineland right down here so
I get there and there's like five people
in line ahead of me and and everybody
like black Latinos are quite everybody
and they're like I mean I like the
chicken the sandwich and so you ever get
to a point where you feel so it's like
you're almost embarrassed everybody's
doing the same thing so my ass might get
the crazy it was five people in front of
me when I when I was in line I ordered
the chicken sandwich then I went outside
to my car to my car with partners to you
on victory it's just you know just to
hang out I go back the lines outside the
door damn yeah so I'm like wow so then
one lady kids got a little bit upset
because she wants to order like four
chicken sandwiches and they would like
limiting two people like to like I think
3 right 2 or 3 and far yes I already got
one I said you know I'm mad I'm not
gonna do this I'm not gonna go in and
get four or five sandwiches got the
sandwich so I'm driving I'm talking to
the people and I'm going loud I'm like
yeah I got the sandwich yeah by my
weight that get home to somebody just
goes eat eat the damn sandwich it ain't
trippin on me I'm like I got the goddamn
sandwich you know so I take a bite no
come gather eating a lot of mcdonough
letter Cuban sandwiches I bet that the
bread sweet know he heard along the
chicken making spice cuz it's already
hot you know it's not the brittle sauce
is no it's the ribbing you gotta
remember it Popeyes Chicken reg Lee
really have malicious oh oh my god I put
it up there was Church's Chicken
but you know what I put Popeyes with the
original kentucky fried chicken skin
flavor like it's something about that
eat some of the original original fried
chicken that nothing Rica recipe the one
that came out way before you got spicy
no right the original recipe the really
the one that loose yes yes oh it was
good I remember that [ __ ] eating up a
little box yes and you have the crumbs
so that's the one he goes to he does all
the skin fried chicken but you know what
I only had one sandwich and it was good
and I said okay it is with this but I
wasn't gonna fall in on phenomenon and
then on social media then it got kind of
like it got all political black people
like me
black people folded like you president
like here we go
I wanna come we don't we don't live we
don't control the electro side with what
a piece of dough but yeah you have
nothing how exactly were like during
during Christmas in 2000 I was 16 a
bunch of people bought up tamale dough
to make tamales okay hey by the corn the
corn me or the core hugs then all that's
gonna be rotting and was that my aunt
over there and South Gators on the grill
yeah so - do it the head like Top Model
gate you know other people were talking
about my Christmas was ruined
you worry about [ __ ] your tamale dough
me if some people don't get president
[ __ ] isn't it funny though how each
nationality each race has some type of
issue within its race like you know
black people you know we talked about
this - that means everything you don't
mean it's just crazy man like John
remember when the people I saw a meme
about the the turkey said what the
[ __ ] eye Popeye sandwich somebody said
oh so you get about going to wrong
corner over there - awhile that place
with all the UFOs all right area 51
everybody forgot about area 51
we got the aliens the people we're
tagging each other cuz they were gonna
go hit up New Mexico area 51 where they
hammer the UFOs yeah they're all gonna
break in Jesus but you know what's crazy
now every restaurant and every type of
like a business fast food is promoting
chicken now Wendy's got a chicken saying
I have got a chicken someone else got
like a chicken and waffle them it's like
WB black show business get B they cancel
it just like the Black Hills I know man
the jacket abides always had their thing
there's chicken sandwich is the number
five the spicy one is too good but
talking about like it was not beaten is
better than [ __ ] for late and I've had
chick-fil-a now these two think about it
the chick-fil-a
yeah yeah that's cool but it's something
about it's just something about I think
he's I think the chick-fil-a is really
about the atmosphere of chicken
cleanliness yes yes can we help you
they're happy you were like three
sandwiches just three chicken sandwiches
for this fine young man you give people
benefits and they start acting eating it
I hop at Waffle House Waffle House we
might get in there before would like
email dumbass he gave me this bathroom
which one would you enjoy
amen
Waffle House two things you know you
know why you gonna leave you better hope
you don't get shot up and they'll play
around at the Waffle House yeah that
fourth time that guy the poor guy was
I'm cooking taking orders and serving by
himself to everyone I was left you were
the only one I was there like a soldier
yeah tired of it no lemonade by the way
copy cold no more shakes daddy I know
you no shake no shake I love my shakes
man yeah but the Waffle House you got to
give it to it no I'm seeing all if it
reminds you of the White Castle burgers
is just something you gotta have at 2:00
in the morning is anything that was
American cheese on it is box yes yes I
think they cast out extra work done okay
what nationality are they Lula they just
came from [ __ ] somebody up there were
an accomplice in the crime yeah
definitely
women are cellblock H so where you from
what you grew up morning New York New
York Manhattan I was raised in a Red Hat
I was raised to Philadelphia helium
right yeah
Sampson yeah yeah I'll tell ya not
beautiful people with their bad man
Philly's a good town bro a New York do
well I don't know about is not right
next to you you should be ashamed
forgive you two reasons when you FLE
pays wife and two I went to college in
Ohio where I'm a Buckeye oh you got you
okay yes I went to Ohio State so anyway
we were for the dumb feel of mac and
cheese oh man no the question is did you
get a cheesesteak he did a big one yeah
all right cool Oh me a Philly Philly
rough town Gordon IV I could tell man
yeah Philadelphia's that's why I think
it gets me in trouble sometime I here
cuz I think you've known me for a while
I've never been in the middle of
anything out when I've been in LA but I
have that I have that attitude of look
if we especially comes to business if
we're gonna do business if we're gonna
do it let's do it if not that's not
that's not and that's how the East Coast
New York filled out you know because
it's being a time for Bulls you know me
for bull so it gets me in trouble
sometime but I beliefs caused me I miss
Philly sometimes but it's all in all
boys it's a good tell it's a good town
man but yeah but school in Philly and
then I graduated went to college did my
undergrad out in a small school in Iowa
and then I got my masters from Iowa
State marching what I have a I actually
am on record as the first
african-american to get an undergraduate
degree in the master's in computer
animation oh [ __ ] I went to the first
school that offered it in as a as a
degree in the country and I went to Ohio
State's first accepting their program
what kind of programs with back then it
was what it was what we what we call
in-house programs which means we had our
programmers and house who designed the
sources they know Jenny Otis right
Coley's yes and then and then the artist
which was me and other people we would
design you would use it to do animation
that's so yes I was the first yeah man
Oregon Trail yeah man but but then at
the same time you guys don't know is I I
was a fighter and I started I was
fighting while I was in grad school yeah
so in Philadelphia as a kid and then
when I got to graduate school well
underground I got back into I didn't box
for a while I lost my mind when I was
younger so I stayed out at the game and
then when I got wing work at College got
back in the boxing I want about four
fights in Iowa and then I went to
Columbus and I want 10 12 fights
everyone I want to go to gloves back to
back in honey thing in Charleston West
Virginia so you know the area so that's
what we kind of messed up my animation
career cuz I didn't know if I was gonna
go profession or not and so I was kind
of like one of the on the line and then
I got invited to Sugar Ray Leonard's gym
they took a look at me and then like me
just it wasn't sugar which is that his
people didn't like me so but now they
don't let you know when time you go to a
martial arts to a boxing gym and you got
and you're the new guy in you're not
going against them to you guys you going
against the best could they they're not
gonna let you just come into the gym and
be like dominate so the first night the
first day I was I was nervous but I
still had an amateur style I was kind of
just quick and throwing punches in the
pros sit back but they they know they
got time yeah and this dude was you know
his guiding bird he was kind of weighing
his hand back and forth nine and a half
later I got hit with the right hand and
you know dazed and that's why ya think I
had to change my [ __ ] around so you
he would leave me with a right-hand man
and didn't drop me so you weren't like a
brawler you didn't go in like I was
about to buy had power I had good pal oh
yeah I spied some of the big names that
sparked Michael num before I started
driving email was pretty good but John
was out this way he was runner yeah yeah
a class for you our Fort Worth wait 147
and then in the amateurs at 450 656 now
how about you fool oh yeah I wrestled
145 let's go to Joe just Mountain View
High School was that it gets around
weren't there okay okay wrestled each
other in console Willie - I know but I
mean Willie no Larry Larry landless he
taught us both out of Russell Conwell
yeah yeah he's a Native American he can
show you how to shoot his spear so you
come out to our name we were your first
time doing comedy abs great and why did
you come in the townhouse actually uh I
kept my head cut my brother my late
brother was let moved out here he was
living I and he asked me to he said man
you finished college it's time for us to
go ahead and help you out so come out
here and you know move with me look for
a job and then when I move back to
Philly so you know a good family member
that he was but we know what you know
I'm gonna tell you a crazy story you
remember the own COPO comedy act theater
right yes what do you think Christian I
don't know a chicken Peter cross let's
see that's this is how long I know he's
been in the game and this is how far we
go back this is 92 I'm out I was dating
a girl from Columbus and she came in
from town when I wasn't with me Oh
mm-hmm okay yes so professional openness
so so uh I was dating this girl and she
was in town on business right
so we're having dinner on Wilshire
Boulevard and she says what do you want
to do when you get out here I said well
you know I'm a plan her friends were at
the table I said well you know I'm gonna
do animation I've been applying for jobs
Disney and stuff like that and I said
and I want to get into comedy so the
girl said oh do you she sort of took the
girlfriend said you see the guy behind
you so I look and she said he owns the
justice how ironic it was he goes he
owns the only black comedy club in the
country that was Michael Williams so I
went over and talked to him I said hey
Mike guy said excuse me sir my name is
Danny Green I'm new in town and I heard
you owned the comedy club and he go yes
and the comedy club was not as it was
kind of coming back with Robin Harris
who started there had died so it kind of
went down so he goes uh look here's my
address
come on over and you know to the club so
he took a liking to me and he started
letting me host the open mic like the
open mic part of it before the main show
started and that's how I got my bones
man well there's a show there every day
no it was really it was Thursday Friday
the Saturdays so I had three days there
but LA at that time was so hot for
comedy I mean there was compact yeah but
it wasn't packed in the beginning for
what I was doing cuz I was gonna open
mic part so we were 1015 people
sometimes true people but what he liked
about me was I was always I always and
even to this day I always give him a
show I always gave him a show cuz I
never act like I think all the
comedian's make mistake when they go oh
you know buddy here like two people in
there that means two people pay they get
a show and he respected me for I always
gave a good show when I was hosting and
that's how I got it the townhouse was
before the Carbonite time the townhouse
came right out to come yet it was the
tie was the comedy act in of the
townhouse and then in between there it
was maverick flats for my favorite flat
to the ground yeah and that was what
y'all know yeah and I was one of the
that was the hottest club on Saturday in
ever like literally it would
packed with 200 people like sardines so
no liquor and everybody was high when he
got there so no liquor no no liquor
knows and everybody
but James Andy Brown was the guy and if
you could perform there it was like if
you got seen there it was almost he was
making your bones stick because the
first time I went the I bombed I did
terrible but yeah so then after that and
then that's when um 96 came around 95 96
I mean gotta hook tup and that's when we
started Fat Tuesday you should sort of
Fat Tuesday yeah yeah guy Torry came to
me in battery room huh the belly roll
first before it got to me he was a young
boy I remember the battery room didn't
even last that long they butcher to them
to the room like in the week we blew it
out like Farrakhan sir need to be there
what was your did you work through your
friends yeah well what happened was back
then actually guy actually guy is
starting he's doing he's doing a
documentary one he's working on yeah
okay so he's gonna but whatever was the
riots came the riots yes and when the
riots came a lot of people in Hollywood
stopped coming to LA so they wouldn't go
down and 43rd they wouldn't look at it
and so there was Delta and so what
happens the right came to them Mike got
sick Michael Williams got sick and so
the comedy act was pretty much about to
shut down so there was only other little
rooms around town yeah there was a lot
of rooms like one we got one up like 13
times like that's how many rooms are up
that's cuz they have room in Long Beach
- yeah yeah yes the cage the cage so so
hey so what happened was um guys just
came to me said hey Dan you know I think
about starting a comedy night you want
to be down with me I said she yeah you
right I just didn't know I didn't know
what it would become
so we went well he did we made up flyers
he made up like little pamphlet flyers
man and we went guy and I went to every
single
mall a Southern California
we strip mall every every Pasadena mall
Northridge every Prince Hall Del Amo
anywhere and passed out the first night
sold out next week
sold do you have anybody special on
those shows that you remember it was
just no comments like it was no bus guys
coming up right nobody big it was guy
and guy wasn't big right he was and what
happened was that year he booked I was
what happen was the club was doing well
excuse me and the guy got a writing job
and then God left it alone and he had
buddy Louis hosted for a while and then
buddy hosted for a while I was still
doing a warm-up for the show and then
guy came back for writing and then God
came to me and said like you know I want
you to be the main meaning you're gonna
be the main guys so then guy was he
starts doing you know throwing doing
getting the films and stuff like that
and he booked American History X yes and
when he booked the American History X
his career went like that so he was even
hosting anymore so he said Dan I want
you to take tonight so that's how I
became that's how people got to know who
I was in LA because I only did it for
like Believe It or Not as Fat Tuesday
and guy and I ran Fat Tuesday for the
first four to five years he only did the
first year and a half before it just
happened for him and then I was the guy
and we got everybody I remember when we
got Shaq and cook and Kobe came in with
Kobe I just got the LA air down and the
funny story about that was I was hosting
and Jack who checked Shaq low as you
know he loves calm and yes you know you
love come that's why he had to he has
that rule a world imposes so so Shaq
goes uh we're saying that's how Shaq
would be shocked would be in a crowd
he'll just yell up leave what you
thought about like your mama Mike so so
sweet so Kobe came in I remember Kobe
came in with Tom and Kobe was new in
town and crowd you know up you don't you
ever been it you didn't go to you but
he'll tell you 300 strong
we turned down I kid you chunked down
100 people each week to the point where
we would sell tickets for the next week
that's good not knowing who's gonna be
on we know he wasn't see that's the
problem now they say the powers with the
cover story Hamdi back then - yeah we
saved the Comedy Store era the Kama
stewards about the shutting scars now
huh they mean star it was [ __ ] was
[ __ ] because you never gave you guys
Friday I don't understand and not only
that but what really made me mad about
the Comedy Store and I'm still upset
about it today is we had guys come
through here we had guys come through
there myself included and not once did
they come in and watch the show though
eh
once you become a regular yeah we want
you in the original room they pretty
much used a black talent it's still very
Caucasian yeah yeah Tucker
yeah that we we we we became a very much
we saved the store we discovered Nick
Cannon and let's you know nice table
let's you don't lie on Monday Mike Epps
got discovered a trucker so well we did
and let me tell you guy and I were
during the week so the show is on
Tuesday so after Tuesday guy phone
phones start blowing up you know in fact
anybody with cell phones it was the
house phone so we'd be at the little
guy's house it's a New York number and
it will or be a agent look we we got a
guy coming to town and we just want to
know can you put them on they're gone
it's it's TC so so we named Asteria hat
we discovered we gave a lot of guys a
lot of opportunities and I was very
disappointed in to this day that the
story they really got saved off the
black comics back and they never came in
and just said hey you should be a
regular and I anyone myself I auditioned
one time now I used to hold it down and
then I audition form it's easy go
[Music]
you need work on give me I need work up
I got 200 people every week that think
I'm hilarious I got Denzel Washington to
kill O'Neal I got Magic Johnson ice cube
in my family
Harry we're a car Sun entourage Harry
Winkley concern was there man yeah do
pothole Street
Tupac came in one time he shut out the
place Mike keep your head up
yeah you was Oh to happen right that was
Robert but that wasn't us that was the
money Mike Mike yes in Monday night was
open night and it was the original yeah
and that's when the guy who died the
community my friend Danny Grayson used
to host that night shut up yeah yeah got
killed in a car accident
yeah good guy he was the host and then
Eddie Griffin
after that night would go and have the
big room yeah so we would have the
original room and then like about 10:00
11:00
Eddie Griffin would get the domain room
and then so the audience will go from
the original room to the main room in
economy store never stopped us because
they knew it was making that money they
was making thousands of dollars it has
some white they had to the Wyatt writer
and a back steering joke because yes so
somebody say birthday was somebody said
you know they say the Cather living cold
you just say in the back of the car you
know I don't know about that but I do
know that you know we we saved the store
or June everybody copy your thing they
took it off from us then everywhere
every city did it every big day no they
really took from us to that we started
the birthday dance whoa Club in the
country on Williams was doing that we
was a birthday does no good no but what
it is what we did was we said Norman
Lewis from Norman lemon so he would give
was we would give was $4,000 no life for
final hours of cash and what we would do
is if it was your birthday we would have
to say whoever birthday is you have to
show your ID you get to come on stage
with Pleasant music have you dancing and
we would give you some money or back
then we started sponsoring like like
Karl Kani all these people that work
coming up we'll come and give us clothes
and food booze it's not fun everything
so that we would wear it on stage I had
some ad ones back in there there and
once I have this jacket I have a jacket
right now denim I did I still have it
says fake leather [ __ ] cuz it was fake
leather but it looked like a leather
jacket and I still got it so you know I
mean that's know if I could say if I had
any animosity towards the store or some
some you know they're not entertainment
but just the story it was that that they
didn't give that give the the black
comedians and comics that we had it and
we should have all the comments with
their carry-on wants to come to yes I'm
sure
white comments like everybody came
through because ever I wanted to do do
that night that happened to it was a lie
factor was the same way like you guys
would sit on Monday night Valentine mix
yet another team night will just italico
night of a thousand Guido's butter beans
gorillas for reals what night was you
guys
we were we were Latino night on Monday
night the lamb factory but one time
myself
Merlot Martinez and Joe Diaz and I drove
to to to uh to the Jolla Commons towards
eternity tonight and when we got there
the sign read Taco Tuesday wow talk with
man whatever he called them it this
protease you know we we didn't stray
away from that we didn't it's not
something I want to say this
we didn't stray blowing Fat Tuesday the
main guy came up with it was bad to the
Orleans I'm not sure but it was Fat
Tuesday it didn't it was fatter Tuesday
see that's how I was started Fat Tuesday
was up at the up in the belly room and
then we remembered we would have one
fell down in the main room called fatter
Tuesday but when we blew it when we
started blowing it all out we just went
down there and switched it all I became
better too fat to their Wednesday's and
other places yeah and you know you know
think about the other room length
chapters that was afterwards everybody
was after my man it was after but I
meant like it was it after it died
without after the comedy store one and
I'm still kind of going because what
happened was in in nine in 2001 guy
wound up giving it to Gary Owens and
then Gary Owens took it for a while and
Joe Clair had it at the end right host
no I well he was hosted but eating hell
I think was Alex Thomas yeah I like
Thomas I remember yeah well yeah so then
the laughs fact we came up with
chocolate sundaes
that was Pookie melrose improv was
spiked on Monday yeah but no spike no no
what people don't know spike was around
probably next to longest spike was
around you know like and that night was
a big night and if they ever pay you
guys extra for having those showcases on
your night cuz yeah but I would be
surprised like I'm gonna say maybe I
remember like you know they have
showcase but showcases the for Def Jam
yeah so he's for any show the FGA me but
those regulars they were putting in work
you know were in there when there was
empty that couldn't get a shot and then
and I remember if somebody told somebody
told me all either was there in the back
hatching an egg walking around well let
me tell you something Michael Collier
man nobody here's the thing we I got
paid off the off of a guy paid me so I
mean I wasn't that wasn't bad I was
making hundred fifty tonight so you
figure back then
honey fifty and gas was two dollars I
mean like 45 cent that's like three four
bills [ __ ] a chicken there yeah so
you know it was cool you don't say the
problem I had with that was we did we
held a lot of showcases for people and
unlike what people do today when they
have a showcase they won't let another
regular comedian come on like if they
had a showcase today for you free pay
yeah they wouldn't allow someone that
was a new comedy come on and we did we
said we never shut it down what we did
was like who's the guy you're gonna
showcase
okay you're gonna showcase him we're
gonna put him up second we never put him
up third it was either gonna be first a
second and then everybody else to show
went on and then we ran the Comedy Store
like you guys would run like you go to a
club on the road first comedian would be
could we never book like we don't do
like the ha ha and all the clubs now
that put on so many compounds collar
yeah
we would do now is go we put four
comedians on I would open up the show
okay and then I bring guy up and then we
will put three comedians on $50 $75 in a
hundred that's good so you know we we
will pay people back then money and so
you know I mean I really believe you
know and I think you know it's probably
gonna be a lot coming out in the doctor
money but there's a lot that we should
have gotten credit for and we didn't get
credit for yeah you know and people
don't want to admit it but oh I'll get
throw in their comedy to just within a
hookup
you know I'm gonna tell ya yeah but but
that rule wasn't like that [ __ ] and one
thing about our cio wasn't our room
wasn't no open mic er
I don't know saying you wasn't you know
you wasn't his charm man okay tough
crowd you had to bring it but they were
respected yeah they were it wasn't like
the Apollo no but if you're funny
maybe they're performing in front of
Devo who just looking at you one time
you know reason my foot don't work hey
let me he came on stage one time and
took picked up a comic you know he was
playing around but tiny is crazy and in
the audience down he got yeah you know
and like tiny you know how to play man
like you know I need this arm you know
what I mean Goliath hand off me though
but here's a crazy thing and um I can't
remember what year was but guy and I
went to San Diego to do a show for from
being I don't think was [ __ ] be was
we're just doing I think we're just
doing the set down there for somebody
and McKenna yeah I thought the guy
touring goes hey I won't be a comedian
God said you know okay man you know come
on up come on up to the uh to the uh you
know talk to our spot and he was two
guys that used to drive Nick up from San
Diego Nick was 16 I don't think Nicholas
fit he might be 15 16 and he drove Nick
up like Nick need to show about four or
five times and I think it was like one
on a fourth to fifth time Nickelodeon
was in the house and they needed to want
to do warm up for Keenan and cow
is that what that was right kidding yeah
yeah yeah and I think it was dust to
show he was did and he did one more form
and the rest is history
I mean week yeah yeah he booked all that
yeah right wasn't the show he was doing
kinda like the host or something like
that where the kids show called all that
is it up kid sketches mm-hmm so and then
he got it on Sean yeah so I mean we
really uh we really uh you know found a
lot of people we get we really discover
whether its first TV credit mine even
the improv no my first TV credit was
comic view which I bomb doing there they
aired it no I got lucky 150 or 800 was
the one remember when BT used to do it
as a competition no they said before yes
they've got horrible yeah I know so what
it is as a comedian they would give you
three minutes he'd want me to give me
right home right they were give you
three minutes and then you had to
perform three minutes then you had to
try to advance yeah that's just coming
over yeah Wow what happened was uh what
happened was I went on stage the first
time and I was so nervous because it was
TV true story and I I started with my
opening bit I'm I have this funny bit
and I still kind of do debates about the
police and instead it's like a minute
it's like a mini almost two minute bit
I'm doing a bit because you know you
timing out when you have two minutes to
me only have three minutes to perform
you're trying to time it out so I'm
doing the bed and I'm looking back and I
see the red light so I do two big quick
and I go okay you guys thank you guys
very much in a girl first age and they
go so everybody comes to me to go why
don't you off the stage you had more
time and I had to crowd laughing I like
the red light came on it wasn't a red
light it was the camera
it was telling which camera was hot and
my dumb ass was so scared and nervous I
got off stage so Saudi militant
de miel the top
the producer of he was the producer so
he did me a solid what he did was he
took my joke and put it in the best of
comic view because it was funny remember
coming views to do that they were growth
like different comedians and so they did
it the next year I booked this show
called keeping it real and keeping it
real was a show with Shang Forbes
Jeff Brown and myself and we were three
guys sitting on the couch we never I
never went to work and we were sit about
sitting around the show was supposed to
be up sitting around talking about life
issues and then introducing music videos
for BT but BT changed it and they want
to just putting us in with comic view
but from that so that was my first big
thing and then what happened was Shane
Jeff for myself because we had that show
BT gave us our own half an hour's comedy
special yeah and I blew the first
half-hour yeah and I blew it up I blew
it that's when I had the round of you I
had the red shirt on tonight and
people's like who's this dude and I
killed it does that help you get more
gigs yes or no because the funny thing
was for me was I kind of got trapped
because guy was my boy so I was on the
road with God and I think at the end
when I look back he kind of hurt me
because when I was on the road with guy
it didn't allow me to be that individual
you don't say like let's book him and
then I wasn't aggressive like that
because I always wanted to be a writer
as well and produce films and stuff so I
always felt and I was hearing cook even
back then I would hear comics talk about
how they were a little bit tired of the
road you don't I mean even in the
beginning and and I like a job yeah so
what happened was I said I didn't want I
wanted to get established I did not want
to not have a home base and I learned it
from a guy from wild that the economy
would he said man you always as a
comedian you got to have a home base
because it's gonna be times you're not
gonna be on the road and you got to have
a home base so I just wanted to make it
all a my home base and I never really
did a lot of road gigs but I got lucky
Christ to do a lot of commercials you
know I've done a lot of commercials over
the time and things like that but the
big thing after after the keeping the
real show the bad thing about it was and
this is another history thing from
keeping it real BT came back with
another show the next year
Oh drama with Kym Whitley Vanessa
Calloway and someone else I think show
Underwood and from that show the view
cane so we were the first we were the
first to you know kind of start a lot of
things and such a cliche story of
America first I mean you know me we
really were so but I think looking back
I wish certainly some aspects I would
have did more row because I know I was
strong as a comic but I think also now
looking back it's also a gamble that I
think could that kind of paid off
because I did get established in LA as a
funny guy so my dick was funny when I go
on the road I did well and now you know
with me writing and producing but you
know it's it's kind of all falling into
place
yeah documentary right I have a doc I
just did I just completed it in July I
call it's called the executioners we all
had a chance it's about a boxing team
out of Philadelphia it's the first
boxing documentary of its kind because
most boxing documentaries that you ever
if you research right now are all about
champs of a champ in individual fighter
or individual fight there is not one
documentary about a team and didn't even
know there I don't know much about
boxing but I didn't know there was there
were teams well yeah because kind of
like a race car team where there's like
a lead guy for the gym okay but the
thing is the reason that ours is so
unique is because everybody was
homegrown it's not like like what sport
outside what sports did you play you
play basketball you know have some time
you can have a cousin that lives across
town and you can go like and you got a
club team and you go do you coach a my
cousin's mother [ __ ] begin him ain't
nobody gonna beat us you don't mean so
what happens is your cousins already
plays over there and then he comes to
join your team you guys become a
powerhouse every single guy we had a
record over a ten-year span of 639 wins
and 84 losses and all of those wins and
losses came under that one roof so we
had nobody that we brought in to join a
team so everybody started at zero zero
day and these men Marvin Gordon who's
deceased and Frank Taylor who was still
alive they start
the gym to save the boys from the
streets of Philly and why not building a
powerhouse and over a 10-year span with
that record we also had six guys invited
to the Olympic Trials 76 80 84 and but
out of that we only have one world
champion that was Gary Hinton so I tell
the story about it and I was there i box
there for two and a half years before I
moved but I was so touched about what
happened was I went back to do a show in
Philly two years ago and I asked one of
my old teammates that came to the show
and I was like yo what's going on we got
the talk and I said I knew Tucci the man
who started it had passed I said hey
he's Frank's too alive and he goes yeah
thanks to Allah so so he gave me his
number
so I waked I got back to LA this was in
August I get back to LA I don't call him
to like September October I just
happened I said you know what let me
call him and I said yeah al Loise Frank
till today he goes yeah this is Frank
Taylor now go
hey this is danny green I used to box
for you as a kid and he goes and now
sleep I ain't talked to him and over 30
years or longer and he goes Danny Green
Danny Green Danny Green southpaw felt
the street good finally yeah I remember
you and I almost cried like it's like
dad you know and then so Hollywood treat
yeah yeah holla to you and then what
happened was I just said you know what
someone's got to tell this story yeah
because when he passes if he passed
before us he's gonna go to the grave and
it's a hell of a story man I got the
trailer Dolph trailer to trailer later
what's the title it's called the
execution as we all had a chance and
it's an hour and 40 minutes I've already
submitted it to Sundance don't know them
to get in I know that's tough the
Philadelphia Film Festival the New York
Film Festival I submitted but you know
you don't find out about a lot of film
festivals into like November December
and stuff like that but yeah man so I've
got five screenplays written regular
films that I've had options on one
screenplays I probably have gotten close
to 80 Oh close to eight 200,000 on on
option option deals and so my writing so
it kind of like you got to give up
something to get something because you
know and I know if you want when we on
the road the last thing you thinking
about is writing you don't mean you know
we're writing a screenplay you know you
guys know they like you you like funny
you know oh [ __ ] one o'clock
let's go get some hamburgers and go to
bed yeah comedians and are always
writing yeah yeah yes you know so you
know so I just uh I mean it's it was a
gamble it's a gamble but it is what it
is you don't I mean so yeah what was
sure have you worked on Armour produced
I never produced the show but I worked
on um I did an episode every I did about
five one of my crazy stories is I booked
the TV show Everybody Hates Chris I was
supposed to be a regular on the show I
was supposed to play mr. Corliss and mr.
Corliss was going to be Tichina Arnold
boss
she was support they was gonna send her
to work but if you ever watched a show
they never said they never said to the
work but some be they never gave her a
job this was the only time I can
honestly say I got depressed in
Hollywood I was sad because they just
cut the real completely after audition
and everything no no I shot the pilot oh
oh they took it out I shot the pilot and
everything and mostly everybody was only
worried about whether the show was gonna
get picked up even though Chris was a
star Chris Rock people was just like if
the show gonna get picked up so a friend
of Mines was a writer for in LA he they
I guess they you know they they started
you know doing promotions so he calls me
he said Danny I saw the pilot he's a
comedian
I don't remember don't know if you
remember Lamont Ferrell he was actually
doing very well as writer he goes damn
it I saw the pilot oh my God look he
said you're not in it something like I'm
think he's joking I'm like how do he
said know me our role was good no will
tell you what happened
so about two weeks later I see the first
bus go by
everybody hates Dan it should have been
that I see that I see that bus go to
show the knockout no because it's so
heavy we study it but it's just Chris
Rock
you don't mean Chris Rock knew
show Everybody Hates Chris posters
billboards that comes over about two
weeks did I get a phone call at least
they gave me respect Dan Dukan Medusa
calls me he goes damn it [ __ ] that this
is I won't say that the other word was
he goes Dannan I got good news and bad
news nobody knew I said act like I just
act like I didn't I said well what's the
good news he said the good news is that
the show got picked up
he said the bad news a for Sinise that
we had to cut you you roll and that was
I was literally like who were the dead
division I don't want to give her a job
huh no it might have been that but
probably like executives watch it and
then they give knows yeah 30 but or but
sometimes they do like audience testing
you and then the audience know now I now
want to break it down yes I don't know
what they really I'm gonna raid table oh
wait a right now okay y'all heard some
who will you say so then who I see Chris
Rock what's up brother a little at the
Laugh Factory so I go no no Chris is
cool if you know if anybody knows Chris
Rock crooks Chris Rock is the coolest
[ __ ] me and he's very low-key
like he don't travel with eight nine
people he chose myself so one or two my
said Chris he was Joe dan was us man
y'all cut the character man what
happened and Chris is like and this is
the painful part about Hollywood well
he's got money don't care you know he's
just like he knows Chris it was a little
long I really worked and so we could he
walked into the Laugh Factory nice okay
Steve again and I was like wow bro and I
was really you know because it was it
was a life-changing I mean you gotta
remember the day I shoot the pilot I'm
in the dressing room Terry Crews
now Terry knows me before they grab his
dick huh nah come on man go tell y'all
go for it open here I'm gonna love there
is a very good friend of mine so I so I
go
Terry's there and he goes this guy's on
the show oh my gosh did he just stop
telling other makeup people no just as
though funniest I mean like cherry was
in it so you coming and you like to
start
one of the stars like it's almost these
vetting for you you humping you up yeah
and I'm like so it was it was it was
probably for only time I was really
depressed and then I was up for another
show I was up for two main shows in
Hollywood I was up for everybody I mean
that's a raven I made it to I'm editing
I made it to network for for that show
made it on to the last three people and
then they picked it right rondell
Sheridan they picked him so that's my
you know then after that I decided just
to start doing cocaine so we'd get my
[ __ ] together
and now I'm back I'm back now I know do
you know cocaine
I don't we before yeah yeah do it you
know it's funny you know it's funny it's
funny though I don't do it but I have it
like I have it before I became legal
because what happened is I did some
shows oh man we ain't got no money man
you're here you go brother
yeah thank you or people just I mean
people literally would before they were
selling it people would give me weed I
know house full of it so you know but
you know it you know Hollywood is a
crazy but it's a crazy game and I think
the problem with most people and it's
definitely a definitely a lot of the
young comedians but even some of the
older came up coming they don't know how
to navigate you got an app you got to
know how to navigate through this thing
because you're not gonna be on top all
the time and you're not gonna always be
the guy they want to give money to and
then it when they do give you the money
you still have to know how to navigate
and that's where I think a lot of
mistakes I see a lot of young people
make and I tried to tell them man but
you can't tell these can't tell these
young people no more nothing because you
know with Instagram YouTube yeah yeah I
got million files okay cool
everybody gonna get you everybody gets
that shot everybody gets a little run
yeah
you maintain maintain can you sustain it
can if I say to you hey you know yes you
open up Felipe you you you you you
perform a Felipe but like oh I like you
and um but can you give ten you give me
an hour right are you working in your
out can you and a lot of people can't do
it in a letter file for Robles and a lot
of these Instagram comedians and people
like there they really can't do it and
they're not thinking post right can you
save your money
some of the people that have like
millions of followers do comedians they
become hosts yeah I don't here's the
thing about me I'm never one of those
guys around and talk about hey you and
me I don't sit around the talk about
yeah get your house up I'm from
Philadelphia and we got a thing at your
house get your house beat get your own
hustle on independence yeah do you
hustle you don't you know I know a lot
of people and I could have and there's
people that ask me gonna roll but really
not many but I don't go up to say you're
making I just do what I do me on dog
everyone everybody wants whatever you
lost yeah you know me everybody wants to
be put on but what have you done to be
put on you know I'm saying so it's a
wild game I know I will tell about some
funny comics that I saw bTW back in a
day that under you know someone's had a
final that got one can we mention Darryl
Heath know he's to come to my show there
he is
his little black suit to miss L tumor al
tumor yes our very funny guy what
happened that brother
um I think scenario I think a lot of
times man you know you I remember to
somebody's always don't this is what I
was trying to tell the public don't
think every comedian is rich was it
comedic no don't think he was a comedian
before he became a comedian
somebody thews was hustlers some of
these dudes would knock you the [ __ ] out
at any time like they got like don't
think this is funny guys here they're
lucky right so what happens is when you
start when you start getting people
taking you over or do me dirty not
everybody's gonna play that PC roll
political role
what's okay don't even like me [ __ ] you
and you do it again you gonna be laying
you were getting up you owe me so some
of these guys left the game because I
wasn't putting up with the crap you
don't mean and again it's about
navigating I think it's about knowing
who to deal with you know like I've
dealt with a lot of stuff out here but I
always my whole thing has always been
this I don't get into like I don't do
like I don't do a lot of bagging I don't
get into these what office yeah I don't
do that could see my thing is when I put
these up I mean it you don't mean for
real
I'm a born warrior right no I'm not I'm
not for real I'll just uh I'm not
putting when I put my hands up in this
issue it's gonna be a [ __ ]
issue it's not I'm not slap boxed I'm
not doing all that [ __ ] so my thing is
imma be as funny and he'll tell you I
love me I will fall on stage I don't
care I'm as silly as they come but
that's on stage off stage I'm thinking
about okay what's my next move now if
I'm around people I know and enjoy I'm
the coolest funny's do but so a lot of
these dudes that you don't see anymore
cuz these guys like me I'm not standing
in for this [ __ ] screws yeah you know it
some dudes lots of room walk Dexter yeah
man this news I had to put some work in
you know to me
Bopha yeah but you member cutler do you
remember Reggie McFadden yeah he's
always talked about he was genius
funny he's a guy and clean-cut top of
the world clean-cut guy here a to deal
and disappear HBO's had the HBO half an
hour special and I'm Sam yeah so that's
just if I'm trying to make some time man
you know you get to the point I mean I
think you know what if we're using exact
yeah you know we'd say I don't mind in
the front and hit a bit about starting a
pillow play pillow fight with the ladies
at children's domestic violence well he
did it without even saying anything wow
he just did the pillow fight physical
movements right and then his face
getting arrested and and then like he
had one more she goes in and throws one
more pillow I had ways in the car I mean
II gotta
there's drugs at this party so I'm just
saying he's a guy that had a special
charismatic all that [ __ ] clean-cut
clean-cut do like not a not a hood do
clean-cut everything but I think what
happens in this business is that people
and I thought about leaving in a couple
of times but I said to myself if you're
gonna do it you're gonna do it and
everybody Tom comes it's just about
really corny gee what couldn't you but
you know he's sick now he's got yeah
he's here he has a back he needs it I
think he has a bad kidney but he started
comedy but he's his health has been up
and down but you got Courtney G you got
that brother Darryl Heath what nice now
if it's not Eddie Murphy now here for
the very very funny guy [ __ ] funny
I mean retarted funny but I think I
don't you know what and I have to say
this because I don't want to spill them
that movie though I'm Black Dynamite
last time I saw him know the other movie
he was in comparability don't be a
menace him Alice Thompkins you know that
was the improvement was fully yeah yeah
he was a way it was him Chris Spencer
and Dow he'd maybe that was the accrue
yeah and now it's Thomas right Alex
Thomas Chris Spencer down here they were
and they were lighting McCullough
biggest theme it's but Sully was the
writer who was in it but soon it was
more than yes so I mean you know it's
it's one you know entertainment is one
of these things that people don't
understand and sometimes we don't
understand you know but I think it's
deals with I don't really think it's
deals with egos as much as in the end
especially with comedians comedians are
really people to like people you know if
you really look at us we're really
people to like people who just wanted
and feel like we got something to say
yeah and we just want to say on a funny
in funny terms you don't mean but unlike
actors you know actors gonna be me and
[ __ ] you know they just want to act now
I'm like me you doing you making
millions you you you you reading paper
words and yeah what the mad about I know
Danny you see what happened to you with
everybody hate Chris that happened to me
a hundred times
that's a painful ban that was that was I
never heard somebody getting cut out of
the pile I heard somebody not getting
continued on to the series after the
pilot doors
I never heard of somebody getting cut I
was cast learn to read through but you
know what I'll tape but I will tell you
this and our fairness Ali Leroi I Leroy
man yes sir did me a solid
he I called him up after the first year
cuz the first shot couldn't call I was
just so down cuz bro it was a hit it was
a hit freak show you don't mean I'm like
damn I could have been there you know me
and you know the funny thing about what
the funny thing about when you get a
deal cuz I because when I did faster
Raven I signed my deal when I had when
you go to network you know you have to
sign your deal before you go to network
because they they have to you have to
know you're gonna know what you're
making and this way if they pick you
you're not allowed you won't be able Ike
renegotiate none like that
so this was for Disney I saw my deal I
was gonna make seventy five hundred the
eight thousand a week do you know I was
like the first you see this much the
drapes delivering Roscoe's now this is a
I gave the room to scruncho I go in I
read for that's a raven i go to network
it's uh street it's me I suppose
Rondo Sheridan and I forgot Lamont
Johnson Lamont Charlie maybe from house
party used to play the third do know how
they're my jobs about yeah real nice guy
yeah so we do it and they said we'll let
you guys know next week
now the week before we had to go to
network how do I kill these two well
Voges no no I've thought about that Wow
you gotta be some poison I can get these
[ __ ] you don't mean the week
before 9/11 hits down so we can't there
first
yeah I know yeah a leader died after
because I was on a cruise ship or no
same mmm Aaliyah diet in the summertime
right but it was right after it was okay
so so cuz I was only I was on a cruise
ship that same week when she got killed
in the Bahamas uh-huh
and we had heard about it like we were
cruising past the Bahamas when it should
happen so 9/11 comes they call us a no
no we're not going to network this week
we're gonna go to file a week so I'm
like okay go do go do the audition they
said we're gonna know they actually is
to reverse I do the the I go to network
they said we're gonna let you guys know
within a week and then 9/11 happens so
then two weeks go by so I didn't tell
anybody at first like you know cuz you
know how we are as in it and this and
that's another bad thing about us being
actors and stuff you don't want to share
it with nobody could you feel like I
wanna jinx it good thing you don't get
it your life miserable right yeah you
don't mean makes everybody right so I go
to church right and you know I'm not
telling people about it and then
eventually tell one person and if you
don't do my black people when you tell
one person you told your total honey
fifty people so people come up to me you
know that's no rule that's over I'll see
you in that role God is in your code
it's your time it's your time well you
gonna get it so years so written for you
two weeks I'm going to church you know I
saw the start yeah you should have came
here two weeks before the two weeks now
here's the funny thing
two years ago by comet eight nope they
have hearing none
my Asian coffee so finally another week
go by so I call my agent up I'm like hey
did you guys like do you know if they
pick somebody yeah my agent as
nonchalant as it is not go not comedian
shut nonchalant and I'm not nuts Allah I
represent rondell movie as as cool and
his mellow and I'm thoughtful as ever
she just goes oh I forgot to call you
you didn't get the part you did
I didn't oh and that was like she's just
she goes oh I forgot the car you didn't
get the part
hello's lunches so I've been closed I've
been really close I've been really close
twice man I hear man I really you know
but I can't network I've never been
through network that's good man yeah
network is yeah yeah network um if they
hold your daughter the whole dream do
you not know you didn't get it I did get
a holding deal what's he know the
network thing was I want the network
because I actually when I did I was an
actor then yeah I'm pretty good I went
for original auditions so it was like I
had went in against so many people and
then not even really know [ __ ] about it
really be honest with you I didn't know
I was just next I know hey good go up to
Disney you know this is nice sign this
can talk about this thing oh my god yeah
then I get to this one page if you get
the part you happy but man you know it's
it's it's the it's the lay of the land
man you know whatever laughs but you
know what though and i and i'm and i'm a
share this with anybody any of you
people we share with you guys two men
and I mean this never in anybody that
you deal with don't ever complain about
Hollywood and I never do that and I tell
people this why I said cuz Hollywood did
not come to Ohio State
knock on my door and go hey you want to
give up your master's degree come out
and make $25 and a lot of people tell
you no and lie to your face No
that was a choice on me so that's why
you'll never ever hear me you know even
if you followed me on social media
whatever you don't ever hear me say oh
this casting directly like some people
will go off and I don't do that because
this is something I picked the only
thing I don't like about Hollywood
ending out and I and I get in trouble
because I don't bite my tongue on it is
when you tell me something if you if you
tell me that you want to meet or if you
tell me you're gonna do something then
you don't do it it's hard for me not to
because it's like you don't respect my
time and that's my only issue otherwise
you're never ever hearing me get on
there talk about people talk about fake
you all right this person I know about
Pierre Stockwell so I just don't do that
man I just don't do that
you know that's me man I just try to
keep you I think it's it helps you broke
you know because if not you know and I
know just this this business can have
you you know jumping out of buildings
you know people and people have done it
you know me commit suicide because they
get so much pressure I know people will
complain them all beats he kept all the
money well they paid you already yeah
but I mean they use that little vehicle
to get your ass book and all that other
[ __ ] yeah
they did they did actually made people
stars though well they make well what
happened is they gave you an opportunity
to become a star right without pay
that's what he really was cut my hair
for cause my half an hour and cooked my
stuff I got paid all with you know jobs
you know DL had sued B et know but they
was using his when he was hosting and he
won you don't mean but deal had the
cached to be able to do that you know I
don't have that you know other people
don't have it but that's why he won and
then de and then McGarry one later on he
became the host to yeah well it was what
DL was the first main host
for the first two years I believe and he
didn't have to like you know he was the
guy they picked and do blew up from that
and got his own show and then after that
BT picked I think it was Cedric the
first year wasn't yesterday Cedric the
first year and then they made it a
competition thing where they're like
okay we're gonna like the year I did my
half an hour which was [ __ ] because
I think they knew who they wanted they
were gonna pick they say whoever had the
best half an hour special they were
going to pick
to be the host and I knew I killed it
and that they wouldn't have me as though
it was it was a done deal
so that's it man that's my BT story what
date of the documentary come on well
find me when I can't find it right now
because what's going on in festivals and
stuff like that well yeah and and and
let me tell you about these film
festivals you think the Mafia is
gangsters they don't play rent what and
what I'm saying is the film festivals
like I haven't even had a screening yet
I thought people have seen it because
I'm pitching it to people but I haven't
had a screening or a private screening
because the film festivals they don't
want you to have shown it they want to
feel like they're the ones first putting
it out there
so that's one reason I haven't had like
a premiere of screening for it but I've
gotten great reviews on it the trailers
been good yes yes and that was it and
that was another thing too so I did it
about the last up to last year I I was
doing very well commercially I had
booked a number of commercials I mean
I'm I was making
80 over I think for at least two or
three two years I had made sixty two
hundred thousand each oh nice commercial
and I love you guys know you know I was
the original Popeye's Chicken dude if
you remember that you know I was before
the girl because dead before they got
her I was the guy I was Charles I was
Charles to cook yeah that was my
character's name so I had me some and
what happened was uh I did a show for
this guy and he had a gang of equipment
there and I and I said hey you know what
are you guys doing here I got my own
cameras and stuff like that and to make
a long story short I went to him and
said would you be willing to go into
business with me on this documentary so
I gave him some numbers he I told what I
could bring to the table how much money
I could bring he told me what he could
bring and then he said he said you know
I'll do a deal with you and it was the
best thing that could happen because
it's great when you have when you do
business with someone and they not
hounding you for the
money pretty much easy you know not told
him o'clock because you know I keep
updated with him because I produced the
whole thing I wrote it directed narrated
I went up to Philly three times a shot
with the North Carolina and shot with
New Yorkers shot and I shot in LA I got
mark Breeland in it I got buddy McGirt
in it call those palominos in it yeah
yeah Sam Watson I got like a lot of good
names in it and I told my said look me
I'm gonna do the best I can to try to
give us a deal and he was just like look
man if we get a deal we get what he said
but the main thing is we got it done
takes a lot of takes a monkey off your
back it takes a lot of pressure off of
you man because today's timing everybody
everybody wants their money you know and
rightfully so you wanted me but it's a
great dock the posters done I'll show
you the poster oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] with died
when I was on here but the poster I'll
show you the poster but the posters done
the trailers done and so we're pitching
now we're trying to you know and
hopefully somebody will uh you know I
think to answer not answer it but to
give you a little bit more insight on
that part because I think it's
interesting
i'ma tell you know I'm telling anybody
in in Hollywood or if you can get it
done get it done on your own because if
you walk to a guy if you walk to LeBron
James if you walk to a sign fell all
over your Spielberg or ice cube and you
go hey I got an idea and you know of
this guy got this script you know
they're gonna yeah because what because
what they're saying is this how much
money do you need you only mean so when
you can come to that table and you don't
have to ask them for money and you said
look it's done I just need a deal you
know I want to buy it they talk to you a
little different yeah you don't mean and
so that's what I'm at right now may I
submit it to Sundance and if I get it to
Sundance I mean that'd be that I mean
you I would you know that people must be
like even if I didn't do Noth nothing
I'll be like cuz son answers I was
surprised I didn't know how many
submissions they get Taylor Lord our
brother
Steve that's out man yeah yeah but
documentaries and sports documentaries I
don't know and it's really a good story
and it's not I have it's a period piece
documentary which makes it even it was
tougher to do because a period piece dr.
Mary you know when we grew up
it wasn't cell phones it wasn't you know
if your mom had a v8 if you had a VHS
you was doing pretty goddamn good yeah
right but you had to be adjusted house
there like hey you know Larry got a VHS
yeah Larry and they rent movies yeah you
know and when movies grow so so watching
these guys didn't know so the footage I
got I got lucky where two of the guys
had some of the amateur fights on this I
was able to get to pull that footage and
then I interviewed the main promoter
Russell pelts who did all the pro boxing
promoting out Philadelphia he's in my
documentary and because of him I was
able to buy footage from him so from
pictures and the footage I had just
enough footage because there's more of a
human story it's about dudes man that
really were right there but the streets
got him you know from drugs to dudes got
shot too not all they're all living in
there doing good now but like it's funny
to see dudes 16:17 man you look at him
now you're like oh these here's a nice
Doody and then but when you go back and
look at where there was a 17 life this
[ __ ] was not somebody to measure
he was not to do to meet in alley you
don't I mean and they gave me some great
interviews and I did it differently than
any mostly any teen documentary cuz most
team documentaries like basketball
baseball football they'll get the
players you know how to get all the
players in the room together and go so
Jim you know when they when he came to
the to the team what do you think about
the wiris [ __ ] boy I knew he was gonna
be a good you know I didn't do that
because what happens is now mentally I'm
only gonna make a comment off of looking
at Felipe you know I'm saying but it's
different when you do individually I
individually I interviewed each fighter
individually and they were able to talk
about the other guys and themselves and
each just said I really knew they knew
each other because they knew the story
you know they would say yeah he was
dissing he was that in perspective right
right exactly
so it's it's a I think it's a real good
documentary I've got people that so far
I'm getting good reviews I'm pitching
some pretty good name so far and we're
waiting here back and yesterday I really
got blessed that one person wants to
read it see it I mean I see it he told
me I wanna put his name out there but if
this do you look up people if they if
they want to do it then you know yeah
and I mean and then I got five
screenplays ready to go
so I mean but this is what it's about I
mean this is the game we in and down
it's easier to come to Philly busy
sleeping you know man I got this deal I
need you do this part you know what I
mean now it's different though I mean it
sounds crazy acting classes too like you
were taking acting classes for the last
two years trying to like stay ready but
you know every week which is funny is
you really have to you have to be ready
but you'd be ahead of the game yeah so
but that's navigating yeah and a lot and
I'm telling me I want you to big three
tournament yesterday all right kid thing
yeah yeah and not just networking over
there and I luckily my boy who was
Reggie Theus who used to play the NBA
yeah you know the Reggie is right that
so Reggie I play golf with him so he
gave me tickets right you know I walked
in with him actually and then he put me
down to the floor so I'm like Michael
Braxton's there the floor is there
that's where I'm at I'm sitting here and
Charles Oakley and then we're there you
know come up when I because when the
person who see that was sitting came I
had to move slide over there but a lot
of but a lot of people bro they don't
know how to network that's a [ __ ] art
you can't go up to somebody wanting
something yeah but they know they know
you want something don't get a twist it
they know you want something man but
I've seen it not know use it was [ __ ]
you know what it's like you know it's
like you ask my come with you ask to an
autograph but that don't even
acknowledge the person you already
talking to giving the autograph - it's
like I can make an autograph like can I
sign this [ __ ] one way if you
know so it's an it's really it's a skill
man and I really it run good day it was
a good day yes to my podcast Mike you're
right now
what's up what your Instagram people
follow its Danny Green six six dan and
da and a no and green six six and then
Facebook I don't tweet I think we can
get you in trouble and I and I don't
like it's got too much to say man what's
up with your watching right now or
listening right now on Tuesday at two
o'clock I'm at Sylmar tonight I'm doing
Spanish or a satorious first come first
serve is free tomorrow now you're gonna
be September 4 is I'm in Tijuana Mexico
Rodrigo tourists at antigua bodega they
pop in a club it's a theater space yeah
it's a small club theater Lancaster
California September 7th Lancaster
Performing Arts Center that's almost
sold out last May in the badass
September 13th finisher Island casinos
in Sacramento September 14th crest
theater kabaah zone California on
September 15 more on go casino ooh
Arlington Virginia September 20th or
21st on 18 Drafthouse at that's the play
that's a movie theater and a comedy club
in 95 and a bar so you can sit there and
watch old movies and have a beer El Paso
Texas September 27 plus a theater I'm
bringing a bulletproof vest I'm showing
up he's gonna go to Walmart September
28th at the American Bank Center
Helena's auditorium Corpus Christi Texas
she you been to over there right yeah I
like I like the idea is a comic strip
Chico's tacos
yes comic strip that was a good club
good crowd good Club a lot of people man
you know so doing it man shows coming up
he'll W I got one I got one in city of
Commerce is Friday
follow me on instagram Roque Johnny
broke it Johnny
September 10th in Riverside at the life
Art Center we have P bellows jokes is
back 8 p.m. with the do it wasn't was a
lot of theme whatever
you know what you need Tober bro come on
no jokes I go out there man come on my
lamb brothers love me even dogs got beat
up by one time when the shirt is
buttoned up to his neck lead him on
how's your ego to Nolan and it hurt less
yeah you said you got stung by a spider
Wow Oh III didn't know bro so we're
about a woody I went to the podiatrist
this morning I couldn't take any more
and she goes oh no no no no this is
infected it has post it's very effective
because it's it's an ingrown toenail
it's infected but what I'm gonna did
infinitely go toenail gets in the bottom
it's going in right now oh [ __ ] here we
go four shots bro she give me two shots
right where the pain was to numb it and
that [ __ ] was like dance brother I did
oh yeah leave it to buy a stick
she gave me two two two all right then
chicky that she pulled on iodine made it
purple then she wrapped it with a
tight-ass rubberband on my toe she's
gonna blade
I went in there bro started cutting
around it and it popped up bro like oh
nasty then she knows oh yeah then I
thought she was done but she wasn't
names Tony
she got a [ __ ] clip a clipper and
clipped it all the way to the bottom but
I can hear you go snaps to your nail
babe yeah and then got a poker and I
cleaning inside where the number was and
it took like oh man how are you walking
Robin that way I'm walking bro he glad
it ain't my total like my team was like
I'm gonna get you sucka
so when you got the treatment done with
her and she took care of it it came back
when I came back was that over the face
we painted with the travel of it yeah
but he also was taking about medicine
putting that medicine on topically that
fixes fungus but causes ingrown toenail
problems is acutely so he's still trying
to get healthy he hasn't been using that
topical solution but they're still like
carryover yeah because I got a topical
solution TJ and made my nail go like
this yeah it can messes up your this
messes up ingrown toenail wise you know
he's done with the medicine so I think
this might be you know what happened to
me one time but it look like had an
ingrown toe just [ __ ] yanking money
out your ass
well we have tests Hellboy Nick you know
Kevin Hart but I'm glad all right yeah
he's getting a [ __ ] in the back of
the seat right before his wife's trainer
and her fiance oh it was a train
[Laughter]